revista de prensa con rosa pérez más de
un rosa bienvenida a feliz jueves ya
estamos casi finalizando esta semana que
se ha pasado volando pero vamos a
empezar entonces en la materia que nos
concierne en moscú times el cambio
climático define algunas de las fuerzas
y debilidades del optimismo este es un
artículo que hizo marc galeote y rosa
extracto y galeote y lo que ha querido
estudiar es el cambio de las políticas
climáticas rusas dice porque es un caso
de estudio interesante teniendo en
cuenta que es un sistema político tan
centralizado y tan personificado en la
figura de putin y señala que si bien en
vladimir putin así como xi jinping no ha
acudido a la copa de glasgow las
críticas que ha hecho particularmente el
presidente estadounidense joe biden son
un poco tramposas porque dice si bien
putin era un claro escéptico con el
cambio climático sobre todo con el rol
que ha jugado ahí la intervención humana
porque recuerda que en 2003 vladimir
putin pronunció la famosa frase de que
en un país tan frío como rusia dos o
tres grados más no harían daño
este discurso ha ido evolucionando hasta
que ha prometido la neutralidad de
emisiones para 2060 y dice a qué se debe
este cambio pues sobre todo a que
vladimir putin si bien centraliza el
poder
se deja aconsejar por las élites que les
señalan que el cambio climático tendría
efectos devastadores tanto en el
deshielo de algunas zonas del país como
en la desertificación de otras y que eso
tendría fuertes impactos tanto
económicos sociales como militares así
rossi recordemos por supuesto que esta
revista de prensa está dedicada
completamente a este cambio climático
vamos ahora con al yazira sin adultos en
la sala los líderes criticados por la
inacción climática esto es de robert
kennedy este artículo lo que recoge es
un recopilatorio de voces críticas de
militantes climáticos que desconfían de
que en la cop 26 se alcancen soluciones
que den una respuesta realmente eficaz a
la urgencia climática porque señalan que
así como en 2015 se llegó a grandes
compromisos que finalmente no se han
cumplido o como en 2009 de acuerdo a la
financiación de los países pobres por
parte de los países ricos para ayudar a
la transición energética pues que el
cambio climático como ya hemos comentado
es una realidad más presente que nunca
de hecho y señala que uno de los
principales temas que hay que tratar con
urgencia y que estamos lejos de abordar
es dejar de financiar la explotación de
los combustibles fósiles pero ya no
fuera del propio país sino dentro del
mismo país y que hay que imponer a los
bancos como por ejemplo a los fondos de
inversión como la croc que dejen esta
práctica y también los estados que dejen
de dar subsidios rosa vamos con the
gardian la desinformación climática
aumenta sustancialmente en facebook
según un estudio este artículo lo hizo
car y paul este artículo lo que señala
es un estudio hecho entre real facebook
oversight board con el stop funding it
dos organizaciones independientes que
han analizado a cientos de miles de post
en esta red social que llena tantos
titulares recientemente
pues expanden desinformación acerca del
cambio climático y también sobre niegan
digamos la influencia de la acción
humana en este fenómeno y de hecho han
detectado que en el último año aún han
aumentado un
76% las interacciones con este tipo de
equipos y por otro lado en otro artículo
del mismo medio señalan como detrás de
estas páginas hay personas como steve
banon recordemos ex asesor de donald
trump vamos con frena first el orden
climático no es el experto en el orden
internacional no está preparado para la
crisis climática este artículo de
stewart patrick especialista en
gobernanza global y desafíos
transaccionales este artículo como la
mayoría de los de forem affairs es muy
extenso y bien complejo hemos querido
señalar solamente una de las partes que
se abordan en este texto y es que
precisamente el autor no especialista en
desafíos globales señala que el cambio
climático es el mayor reto que
afrontamos como humanidad en tanto que
se requiere una acción colectiva global
y dice que lo que hay que hacer es
cambiar de paradigma y apostar por una
política planetaria que esto significa
poner pues la lucha contra el cambio
climático y la protección de la biosfera
en el centro tanto de la seguridad
nacional como de las relaciones
internacionales o la economía global y
este debate lo plantea en un ejemplo muy
ilustrativo que es por ejemplo brasil
debe considerarse dueño o simplemente
guardián de la amazonía en tanto que
toda la humanidad no depende de la
amazonía para la supervivencia y señala
que los distintos países la comunidad
internacional debería tener más recursos
para intervenir si en un país como
brasil está explotando un recurso que es
vital para todos rosa de flor isla va
este esta viñeta no pues a mí me
encantan las viñetas raúl porque con
poco texto se puede decir muchas cosas y
es el típico juego de niños no en que
uno lo dice al otro pues en el suelo es
lava
pero básicamente se puede traducir este
el suelo es lava sin intervención toda
la casa será lava para 2050 se puede
traducir por sin intervención todo el
planeta será inhabitable para 2050 tanto
para las futuras como para las presentes
generaciones web rosas muchísimas
gracias entonces por todos estos
titulares de la prensa esta revista de
prensado y muy interesante sobre el
cambio climático mañana nos vemos con
más vamos ahora con nuestro primer
invitado del día